le mouvement ni put ni soumise organise
ses deuxièmes assises à Dourdan dans les
son cela peut en surprendre certains qui
pourrait y voir une tentative de
récupération mais beaucoup de politiques
sont en effet présents notamment des
membres du gouvernement les femmes de ce
mouvement cré en 1999 s'en explique
Serge Chimino Nathalie
Bertier Fadela Amara joue les hotèes
d'accueil pour une journée PIP la
présidente de Ni put ni soumise recevait
du beau monde ce midi à déjeuner entre
intellectuels journalistes et humoristes
quelques membres du gouvernement sont
venus assister aux Universités d'Automne
du mouvement en tête Jean-Louis borlot
ministre de l'Emploi avec sa cohésion
sociale en bandoulière loin d'accepter
le reproche d'une récupération politique
il lui semble logique que l'État
accompagne le mouvement il y a pas d'un
côté les
associations qui ferait simplement
bouger les
idées moi je souhaite qu'elle soit soit
impliqué dans l'opérationnel donc dans
cette opération logement ghetto elles le
sont et elles le font et bon ça c'est du
partenariat entre nous cette deè édition
des Assises du mouvement intervient 2
ans après le drame de Vitri sur scène où
la jeune Soan avait péri brûlé vive un
tragique fait divers qui donnera à ni
put ni soumise créé en 99 une véritable
existence médiatique libérer la parole
des femmes dans les quartiers c'est la
profession de foi d'une association qui
attend des actes des pouvoirs publics
c'est important pour nous qui nous
entendent c'est important qu'il sachent
ce qui se passe et c'est important
surtout que quand on fait des
propositions et ben là où ils sont dans
les les mandats qu'ils ont après tout
ils nous représentent c'est ça aussi la
la démocratie ils le traduisent
concrètement sur le terrain sur
médiatisation volontaire avec ce
déjeuner des parins et marinees du
mouvement un mélange des genes qui ne
gênent apparemment en rien les bénévoles
ça peut toujours servir c'est une bonne
chose qui des artistes et tout ça qui
nous entourent c'est la preuve bah ça
nous valorise et puis ça nous médiatise
et ça nous donne une notre vis
domque de ville hier Jean-Louis borlau
aujourd'hui le gouvernement s'est
largement affiché au côté de nimise il y
a moins d'une heure les caméras en moins
François Hollande libéré de son conseil
national du PS a honoré l'invitation de
l'association